so je baille c'est à cause du changement
d'horaire la nuit a été plus courte mais
pourquoi baille ton juste on ne le sait
pas précisément selon certains
spécialistes le bâillement permettrait
d'augmenter la circulation sanguine pour
refroidir le cerveau histoire de nous
rêver ce que l'on sait en revanche c'est
pourquoi nous mettons la main devant
notre bouche quand nous voyons ce geste
remonte au moyen âge
pas pour protéger nos voisins d'une
haleine fétide c'est une superstition
pour empêcher les démons de glisser dans
la gorge et l'âme de s'échapper
quoi qu'il en soit j'espère que cette
capsule 2d confiné ne vous aura pas fait
bâiller d'ennui à demain et n'oubliez
pas je me confiner mais en restant lien
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus gens
réalisent une nouvelle chaque jour alors
pour ne rater aucune de ces capsules 2d
confiné abonnez-vous et activer la
petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain